الان نستعرض هذه الصور لقصف قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي سياره في رفح قبل
قليل اذا قصف سياره مدنيه في مدينه رفح
وانتشال ثلاثه من الشهداء في هذا القصف
علما بان الغارات مؤخرا على رفح تتركز على
مركبات مدنيه بالامس كان هناك اثنين من
الزملاء الصحفيين حمزه الدحدوح ومصطفى
ثريه واصيب اثنين اخرين في قصف سياره من
الواضح بان سياسه الاغتيالات تزداد شيئا
فشيئا هنا في مدينه رفح تحديدا التي تاوي
عشرات الاف النازحين الفلسطينيين وهذه
الغارات تمثل يعني عمليه قتل وانتقائي
ايضا واضحه من قبل الاحتلال في قصفه لهذه
المركبات وقتله لاكبر عدد ممكن من
المدنيين هذه منطقه مكتظه مليئه بالنازحين
هذه دماء الشهداء هنا كما تشاهدون على
الارض
بعد قصف هذه
السياره هنا يحاول المواطنين جمع اشلاء
الاش هؤلاء الشهداء من داخل هذه المركبه
التي تم قصفه على الاقل بصاروخين من قبل
طائرات
مصيره هذه دماء
الشهداء كل تاكيد هذا يعكس فضاع وشده
القتل الاسرائيلي وصواريخه الذي يستهدف من
خلالها هذه المركبات المدنيه
التي بكل تاكيد يقودها
مواطنين
عزل كما تشاهدون في هذا المشهد امامكم هذه
المركبه مضمره
تماما كما تشاهدون في هذا المشهد هنا الخ
الدفاع المدني ايضا تحاول البحث عن اشلاء
في داخل هذه المركبه بعد ان تعرضت لهذه
الغارات
هذه المركبه من نوع جيب بطبيعه
الحال